[Music]
before you watch winnie-the-pooh force a
sad middle-aged Christopher Robin back
to the Hundred Acre Woods Steven
Spielberg had every 90s kid wondering
what if Tinkerbell forced a sad
middle-aged Peter Pan back to Neverland
I can see why you have trouble finding a
happy thought so many sad memories Hook
gather round for Spielberg's least
favorite Spielberg movie I want to see
hook again because I still don't like
that movie even though it's the best
film in the entire Peter pantheon where
by best we mean least racist most
memorable and containing the fewest
covers of smells like teen spirit
some day I'll actually watch pan to find
out why that's in there but today is not
the day me Peter banning professional
cell phone ever
[Applause]
he is Robin Williams like you've never
wanted to see him before grumpy angry
and completely shaved from head to toe
yeah then they cut the scene where the
Lost Boys went on 40 year old virgin on
his chest when his kids get taken off to
Neverland Peter Benning will have to
become Peter Pan again at the 100 minute
mark of a 140 minute movie how was I
that patient as a kid enter a
spellbinding version of our own world
where the Peter Pan stories are all
fiction mr. Barrie
Elsa James 18 years ago except they're
not because their own based on
historical events the stories are true
except for that one shot where they
imply that everything was all a dream
and if that's not confusing enough enjoy
a family dynamic where Wendy has always
had a crush on Peter
but then she adopted him as her own
grandson after he kissed her
granddaughter on the lips while she
slept
and she still clearly has the hots for
him grandma
that is so Banga wrong head for the
second start of the right and straight
on till morning through the saddest
place you can imagine never lad a prison
island in a state of perpetual war
infested by a pirate army that's
suicidally depressed hmm
don't try to stop me Smee okay yikes
but there's also the Lost Boys
a tribe of tweenage murderers who are
probably starving to death on imaginary
food and can hide the fact that after an
eternity of battle they're all broken
children desperate for some structure
and guidance do you remember your
brother Peter ok how did I think this
movie was fun when I was a kid was I
that blinded by rufio's half shirt and
triple hawk oh yeah he's still the best
so strap in for a movie that if you're
over 30 you probably have really fond
memories of because you focus on the
incredible Hoffman performance the
amazing production design and your
unconditional love for Robin Williams
but when you revisited as an adult or
were born after 1990 you'll realize it's
a sexually charged violent movie about a
midlife crisis that takes two hours to
really get going
but you know for kids yay starring Robin
stood Zen in tights Robin Williams poor
stunt double
[Music]
the shape of water Maggie Smith as the
old lady in Titanic nothing but respect
from my fire horde I can't feel my legs
I Heart Huckabees Peters pram it's me
Mario and random cameos by Gwyneth
Paltrow David Crosby Glenn Close Jimmy
Buffett shutter island' okay I'll just
throw this out there but we're Michael
and John toodles did you kill them I've
lost my novels did bins get lost
Squidward my ASMR voice is a weapon of
mass relaxation Luke you must go to the
Dagobah system my purple moustache
[ __ ] today gosh heck huckleberry
honeysuckle darn it